Star Trek Strange New World season one
available for free
kind of ish welcome to psycheck your
Sci-Fi TV a movie channel
[Music]
so overnight it was announced that
Strange New World season one is going to
be available on YouTube so we could
actually watch it without having to
subscribe to Paramount plus now that is
a bit of a treat because it's actually
the entire series all 10 episodes not
just one or two episodes like has
happened in the past when companies are
doing a promotion like this for a new
series
so why have they done it well Paramount
plus is still relatively small compared
to the streaming services it has
actually still been struggling in Europe
and Paramount as a whole has kind of
been struggling so this is a brilliant
quick easy way to actually get a bit of
hype for the new Star Trek Strange New
World season 2 which premieres June 15th
now don't expect Strange New World
season 1 to be available on YouTube for
long so if you're gonna go and watch it
definitely go watch it now also don't
expect to be able to watch this unless
you live in the United States because
yes they have limited this only to
YouTube in the US because they hate us
if we don't live in America apparently
Europeans are second-class citizens and
never mind the rest of the world but I
wonder if there's a way we could all
enjoy it there is go get a VPN watch it
through your phone or your tablet or
whatever and you know a lot of people
watch TV like that all the time anyway
now one of my brilliant subscribers who
actually sent me the link for this this
morning at 6am thanks Bob
actually thinks this is actually a
negative thing this is just one more
example of how you know desperate
paramounts are to get as much out of
Star Trek as they possibly can why would
they put the entire series on instead of
just one or two episodes in less they
were absolutely desperate well I don't
agree with that very negative view of
Paramount I have told Bob this he knows
that's my feeling
um I think this is actually a very
clever Ploy by a much smaller company in
the past when companies have done this
for example how should the dragon was
actually released the first episode via
YouTube and before the rest of the
series as a way of hooking people to the
new show
they're trying to advertise the rest of
that new season this case they're
actually trying to advertise a musi the
second season so put the new season out
for a short period of time let people
enjoy it let people get excited
let people like me do a video about it
and then drop season two and hopefully
get those viewing figures and those
subscriptions to Paramount plus up a
little bit
because remember again now Star Trek is
really only going to be on Powerman plus
if Paramount plus is going to survive
and it's a big if
they need Star Trek to do well after the
massive hype of Picard season 3 and the
success it doesn't surprise me at all
that they are really throwing all of
their eggs into this basket and doing
anything in everything they can to
ensure people watch strange new worlds
and I think it's a very clever
suggestion
so guys if you've got a VPN or you live
in the United States of America you can
now watch Strange New World season one
completely for free
but guys get to the comments and tell me
what you think is this a desperation
ployed by Paramount or do you think it's
actually just a very very clever
publicity stunt I'd love to know exactly
what you think get into the comments as
always if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out as
we get you all the Sci-Fi news as
quickly as possible
please guys stay safe and I'll see you
next time
foreign